right imagine coming up with 20 small
molecule Inhibitors or 20 antibody
products that's really kind of
challenging to design and then
understand the pkpd of that understand
the safety of that so I think up until
this point it's been really challenging
and people have shied away from that um
but I think with the flexibility of
crisper and bass editing where designing
these guides is is high throughput now
is is more well understood and
potentially using some of these machine
learning algorithms to guide us into
what is the best combination I think is
the next step so hello and welcome to
the Shiki science show where in this
video I spoke with Ryan Murray a PhD
student at Northeastern University where
Ryan has been involved in developing an
immunotherapy that involves base editing
of immune cells to treat cancer well
firstly uh congratulations to you for
getting out the new sort of preprint a
couple of months ago um showing some of
your research and I mean basically this
uh today will be mainly trying to unpack
that work that you've produced so um the
work is all around car te cells and I
know some of my audience are probably
may be familiar with te- cells being
part of the immune system but why is
your fig scared around uh car te cells
what exactly are they yeah so I think
because te- cells are a major component
of the immune system they've been
heavily studied as a therapeutic cell
type so what's called car T cells are
really popular for
cancer indications but now moving
outside of oncology as well so car
stands for chimeric antigen receptor t-
cell so essentially we take usually
little pieces of antibodies which can
recognize certain antigens on cancer
cells and engineer those into te- cells
to redirect them to be able to see in
specifically Target cancer cells so
there's been a lot of research
surrounding this and a lot of positive
clinical and now commercial data showing
that CTI cells are are extremely
effective at treating and curing blood
cancers I see so because um a well from
my initial learning about tea cells was
they target foreign cells so cells that
have been infected by things like
viruses so um I think this whole area of
like Immunology has recently been very
exciting like immunotherapies in
particular because it seems like there
is this innate ability of these tea
cells as you mentioned to recognize
cancer
cells right yeah so they do have this
innate ability which is sort of what CTI
cells are designed to mimic so when
there is a foreign cell or an infected
cell the te- cells will recognize that
um through their TCR and they will
Target that cell for you know
destruction um cancer has a lot of imuno
evasion mechanisms so a lot of the times
they employ these strategies to prevent
that interaction or to dampen that
immune response so the te- cells are no
longer effective against cancer
um there's a lot of um targets that
these cancers Express that are also
expressed on normal tissue so the te-
cells may or may not see those as
foreign or uh negative and not actually
kill the cancer cells as well so I'm
coming up with strategies to design
carte cells either finding a really
specific antigen that is more closely
related to the cancer to tell the te-
cells this actually is a Cancer and not
a normal cell or to engineer the T cells
the CTI cells with something extra um to
help them evade some of those
immunosuppressive strategies the cancer
cells are employing is also something
that's is uh very intensely studied
right now um so really good at designing
C CTI cells to recognize the these
antigens and turn on the immune system
um they've been effective but now I
think the second sort of wave is looking
at these ctis cells and how can we
bolster their efficacy can we make them
more potent can we make them persistent
the patients longer so they survive for
an extended period of time long enough
to actually eradicate the
tumors so just to clarify these car tea
cells are sort of modified tea cells
that are given to patients and then the
idea is that hopefully they can Target
and eliminate these cancerous
cells yeah right now the the pretty
standard in the field is to extract a
patients uh te- cells engineer them in
the lab with the cars and then put them
back into the patients so uh things are
moving sort of away from that as you can
imagine that's really challenging to do
for each individual patient especially
when a lot of these patients are quite
sick and can't tolerate the sort of
processing that it takes to extract te-
cells from the blood you know wait some
time to engineer them in the the lab and
give them back so there's two really hot
topics right now in the field that are
alic te- cells so you can take te- cells
from a healthy donor patient requires a
little bit more engineering to make sure
that when you put those back into a
cancer patient um they don't see those
as foreign as you are had already
brought up because you can't you know
mix and match people's uh cells so
they're a little bit more challenging
but you get them from a healthy donor um
you can put them essentially in the
freezer and whenever you need to
administer them as a therapy they're on
demand or what people consider offthe
shelf so there's no delay in that
engineering and processing if you took
them from a patient putting them back
and now additionally on top of that is
just invivo engineering so you don't
have to take the tea cells out of the
patient or out of the body anymore you
can inject them with
certain proteins or um strategies that
might actually create the car cells in
the body so again it shortens that time
to treatment um that patients are now
you know really struggling with waiting
to get treated so those two are sort of
new and on the horiz Horizon but for now
sort of the standard is taking a
patient's blood out and Engineering in
the lab oh yeah I see so yeah the
standard approach is this all autologous
approach versus the patient own cells
and the idea is to shift to these
allogenic tea cells so you mentioned a
few times now the word engineering now
um I know because I read your prefent
that you work with a crisper technology
and so see a lot of people associate
crisper with Gene editing so would you
be able to elaborate on what exactly
gene mean by the term engineer ing yeah
so I think there's a bunch of different
types of engineering so there's a lot of
synthetic biology strategies a lot of
Gene Gene editing a lot of just rational
design of these sort of mutant car
proteins because these are not natural
right they're sort of fusions of
different pieces of t- cell signaling
molecules and little pieces of
antibodies so they can recognize these
so there's a lot of different types of
engineering um the preprint itself
focuses on um Gene editing so that's one
sort of strategy that we can increase
the potency of these te- cells and
you're correct it's focusing on a
crisper cast 9 technology um called base
editing so I think people are probably
at least have heard the term chrisper
cast 9 it's essentially this protein
that was derived from bacteria that can
specifically go to Regions of the genome
and cut those specific areas so it was
originally a a defense mechanism for
these organisms but we've taken that and
uh re-engineered that to you know do
highly specific genome engineering so
crisper is really great at going to a
very specific location in the genome and
creating double strand brakes which you
know is very good in for creating
Knockouts or inserting certain genes so
in the preprint um we've taken sort of
the the next step in engineering those
proteins and are you utilizing base
editing so it's the same principle
except these proteins don't create
double St braks they just actually
specifically modify one DNA base bear to
another so specifically we using this um
AB base editor which will change um an a
base to a g base so there's no need for
double strand brakes you're not actually
cutting any of the genome and because of
that we can actually really nicely
Multiplex and and Gene edit multiple gen
at once um because there's no
genotoxicity associated with cutting up
the DNA in multiple places as you can
imagine you know cells don't really like
if things are going to be cut and sort
of free floating DNA and then resticking
that back together properly is really
challenging and creates a lot of
negative effects so to get around that
if we want to um do multiple edits at
once we can utilize this this newer
technology of crisper which is base
editing um and really just specifically
change those bace pairs without the need
for double strand braks I see so what
are the sort of like functional impacts
of these bace changes obviously if you
do a sort of canonical crisper double sh
break often that's sort of like Ines uh
insertions deletions and sort of mutates
that region and so obviously uh for
context you're trying to edit particular
genes um I believe and so what what sort
of like uh impacts can you achieve by
just changing an a tog in terms of
modifying what happens to that Gene
great so for um this work in particular
we were looking at Gene Knockouts so we
are looking to create these C cells that
are more resistant to all those
immunosuppressive Pathways in the tum
micro environment so I've alluded to
before that CTI cells are really good at
treating and curing blood cancers but
they haven't really been great at doing
the same for solid tumors so breast
cancers lung cancers um
because these tumors you know are a
physical mass and they create this micro
environment that is much more
immunosuppressive compared to you know
there's not really a concentrated micro
environment for a blood cancer as it's
pretty well dispersed throughout the
body so this creates a a really
concentrated area of proteins that will
turn off the immune system um that will
completely silence the immune system it
will polarize a lot of these other
immune cells that are within the cancer
micro environment to make them proc
cancerous instead of anti-cancer so it's
a much more challenging barrier for the
ctis cells or the immune system in
general and if you um you know think
about it cancer has many many different
ways that it can evade the immune system
I think people are probably also have
heard the the buzz word pd1 um this
anti- pd1 immunotherapy has shown great
results in the clinic um but not
completely Curative in some cases and in
those instances right the cancer can
just utilize other strategies to evade
the immune system so you block pd1 it
has 10 things on reserve that it can
still utilize to block the immune system
so really we wanted to understand in
this preprint what are some of those
other mechanisms and can we find
different Pathways that might synergize
in their immunosuppressive capacity and
can we alleviate those barriers so in
that instance we want to do something
that's more than one maybe more than two
in this case up to six edits and in
order to do that we needed to use a gene
editing strategy such as base editing
which wouldn't cut up the genome with
all of those different
edits I see and so actually when I was
reading your uh paper like one of the
things that I thought was interesting
was one of the modifications you make is
in the adenosine receptor and so is this
a more recently emerged pathway in terms
of suppressing t- selectivity or how
much has really known about it
I think that it's um a relatively
well-known pathway for immune
suppression so actually my lab at
Northeastern um my Pi Misha sovi sort of
was a pioneer of this pathway and
figuring out how does this work to um
suppress t- cells and NK cells in the
immune system and found that it's a
really potent suppressor so um adenosine
is sort of Highly generated in the tumor
micro environment as it is uh
metabolized from ATP so all the cells in
the tumor micro environment especially
rapidly dividing cancer cells are
utilizing up ATB creating ATP at high
rates and is then degraded into
adenosine which is free floating in the
environment and that is then picked up
by um certain cells of the immune system
which then turns them off so it is one
byproduct of cancer itself of just
having a high metabolic rate that then
generates sosine which in turn turns off
the immune system so I think it's well
known that this has effects on dampening
the immune system it's normally utilized
in um like wound healing as well so it
has a positive benefit it's just been
co-opted by cancer um and it's just now
starting to be understood that we can
apply this to bolster ctis cell activity
um for immunotherapies so I think the
the pathway is well known and we just
want to see can we apply that to tea
cells a couple of have looked at this
and utilized sirna or crisper cast 9 to
knock this down and have shown
improvements so we sort of started there
as well with base editing and we're like
can we show that we can also knock this
protein out and benefit te- cells um
which seems to be the case um I guess
you can go back to your previous
question which how do we actually do
that how do we actually get rid of these
proteins so we can design these editors
to go to specific regions in the genome
let's say for the adenosine receptor and
it can make those specific base bear
changes what we're looking for are
regions of the genome that um are start
sites so where the gene starts its uh
transcription translation um we could
disrupt that start site so that never
begins and that protein that mRNA is
never created and then that protein in
turn is never created resulting in a
knockdown or we can look at specific
regions of intron Exxon splice Junctions
so typically you know the exons are the
coding regions and all the introns are
spliced out to create a functional
protein we can Target those those
Junctions which are pretty highly
conserved within the genome and if those
are disrupted the exons are not spliced
properly and that usually leads to
nonsense mediate Decay and that protein
is never created so we can knock out
proteins with this editor in two sort of
different ways by preventing any
initiation with the start Cod on or
disrupting how they're properly spliced
and put together you know effectively
negating their proper translation and
doesn't create any
proteins interesting and so like how
long does it take you to sort of
identify or screen different ways of
trying to achieve this knockdown of
these different uh
genes yeah so I would say that you know
crisper is really efficient at this
since it has a pretty ubiquitous pan
Motif so there are three specific
nucleotides that crisper can recognize
that we can guide it to in the genome so
there's a lot of different places you
can put crisper into the genome and it
will just cut anywhere which is pretty
efficient Bas setting is a little bit
more um restrictive in that way because
I just described we sort of need to find
an A in one of those two regions in the
start code on our sply site um so those
are a little bit more restrictive and
then once we find an a that is within
that protospacer sequence so they also
has a three nucleotide sequence that um
we can guide the base Editor to it needs
to be in this sort of what we call an
editing window so there's um a Damas
fused to this crisper cast system now um
since the system itself cannot create
double Stern brakes if they've been
engineered to have a dmas which will
actually do the chemical conversion of
that a to G so it's not in this certain
editing window which is close to that
Proto space sequence the efficiency can
be really low to know editing efficiency
so um for those reasons we need specific
reasons of the genome and they need to
be relatively close to where the cast is
going to sit within the genome it can
make screening for these sometimes
difficult um but uh we we've been very
efficient in how we can design these and
Screen these um and sort of turn through
them relatively quickly in hopes of
finding a spot in the G though that can
be
editable I see and in terms of making
all these edits within the T Cell you
describe the fact that you can Multiplex
and so are all these six edits that you
describe in the paper being done at the
same time or is it the sort of like
sequential you have the same cell but
you just over time edit it yeah I think
I think the sequential strategy is
something that other places are
employing um because again doing a bunch
of these modif modifications at once
might be uh not advantageous for a cell
especially going to more sensitive cell
types like a stem cell or a neuron um or
if you're using double St brakes and you
can't cut all of these at once t- cell
seem highly amenable to this editing
strategy and base editing doesn't
generate double strand breaks so we just
do all the editing all at once so we
introduce an mRNA that will encode the
editor and then we introduce six
separate guide rnas that will guide that
Editor to six different places in the
genome and edit all six of those
locations at once oh wow okay and then I
guess once you identify correctly edited
cells the the t- cells there's a way to
sort of expand them or how do you go
about um sort of storing these modified
cells yeah so in the beginning of the
process like a typical car T process
essentially you would start with either
patient te- cells or donor derve t-
cells which is what we were starting
with um do all the editing and the car
engineering up front so introduce the
car via lentiviral Vector um and then we
just expand them in vitro per the normal
process that everyone else is using for
cars you know in media with exoin ayine
and at the end we freeze them down and
then they would be ready if they were a
therapy um to be dosing to a patient um
but then we just saw them out and do all
of our QC and analytical assays on them
to make sure that all of those edits
happened and to what degree and then we
stress test them in an invitro and
invivo setting to make sure that
biologically that those Knockouts um
have a substantial effect right making
sure that they're doing what we think
they are doing both in and outside U an
invivo model system I see and so um you
described already how the edits you're
making part of them are to actually aase
like immune suppression so the the
cancer suppressing the t- cells but what
are the other important properties that
are needed to have like effective or as
you describe stealthy tea cells for this
therapy to be more effective yeah so the
the main Crux of the paper was to look
at these sort of different orthogonal
Pathways of immune suppression so up
front we started with the adenosine
receptor and showed that we can you know
for the first time use base editing to
knock that protein down and make these
te- cells resistant to adenosine
mediated suppression sort of been shown
before with sna and crisper but we were
happy to see that base editing can also
be used for this but again the cancer
cells have so many different Pathways
that they can evade the immune system so
we took those adenosine resistant cells
and subjected them to other Pathways
that we found in our model that were
highly upregulated that were relatively
common in multiple cancers namely pd1
and TGF beta and we showed that our
adenosine resistant cells still were
suppressed by these so you can imagine
you put in a cell that has a single
knock out it goes into the patient's
tumor micro environment it sees all
these other Pathways it still doesn't
work so I think that's been the major
problem with these some of these
monotherapies or combo therapies for
immunotherapy right now is it's really
only one or two Pathways and these these
cell therapies are still being
suppressed so we then showed if we
remove all three of these proteins
abating signaling from all three of
these Pathways it really benefits and
bolsters the t- cell Factor function in
some of our animal models so we're happy
to see that you know Multiplex Gene
editing um in this combinatorial fashion
can really enhance ctis cell potency in
the Sal tumor micro environment but we
really wanted to make it translational
so it's great that we've shown
combining uh resistance to imos
supression uh creates a superior product
but as I alluded to before in the
beginning you know everyone is moving
towards this either inv Vivo editing or
allogeneic for uh the the multitude of
benefits that both of those Avenues have
so we are thinking we want to show that
one base editing is really powerful and
can add more and more edits right so far
we haven't been restricted to the number
of edits that we can do in in a T Cell
simultaneously so we want to show that
power and flexibility but also make this
more realistic right we wanted to show
that we can also make an allogeneic CT
cell that is super potent and effective
in um the tumor micro environment so
after we found those potency edits to
reverse the immune suppression we added
in three additional edits that we term
stealth edits to sort of Shield these
carti cells from um immune rejection so
again if we took someone uh someone
else's patient cells and mix them with
the healthy donor cells they would be
seen as foreign and they would start you
know killing each other so we want to
prevent that graph vers host or host
firste graph disease in our cells so
what we did was um utilize Bas editing
and we targeted the TCR so we removed
the TCR from our c t cells so in that
regard these te- cells when put into a
patient would no longer see that
patient's body as foreign and it would
prevent that graph versus host disease
we also layered on two additional edits
um targeting HLA class one in HLA Class
2 so in that instance when we put these
cells back into the patient the patient
patient's body will no longer be able to
recognize um hlas on these te- cells and
see them as foreign and remove them so
um typically that's a a major problem
with allergenic cell therapy is these
therapies don't last too long in the
patients long enough to enact their
affector function because the patients
still have an immune system and are
recognizing these therapies as foreign
and clearing clearing them out of the
body relatively quickly so we added
those three edits into our CT cell
product to show that it could be
translational to the clinic and what we
did was um put these into a humanized
mouse model so these mice uh have a
human immune system so you can imagine
that they're probably as close to a
patient as we can get in a rodent system
um so when we inject our carti cells
into these mice they have a human immune
system which can recognize these as forn
and CER them out we've shown that in the
paper um that pretty readily you know
after a couple weeks we have no
detectable car cells left because the
mouse human immune system did its job um
but when we add in these stealth edits
to prevent that uh removal or aloe
rejection in these mice we can show that
they pers not only persist out uh number
of weeks months but these cells um
actually can enact their full affector
function and fully clear tumors so one
we added the potency at it so they're
more potent Within the tumor micro
environment but then the stealth edits
actually allow them to remain within
this model system or in a patient for
longer to actually get to the cancer and
uh eradicate tumors oh cool so just to
clarify you were initially always
editing like human tea cells which is
why you then needed to have the
humanized mouse model so how do you
actually like generate these uh
humanized immune system in within the
the
mice so these are genetically modified
mice that themselves do not have have an
immune system or do not have a fully
developed immune system so typically
these are used for oncology studies or
infectious disease studies because it's
easy to
introduce um in this case you know a a
cancer model because it can't be
rejected by the immune system so they're
sort of a blank slate um that's a
standard in the field and then on top of
that we just utilized um human stem
cells so these can be infused with human
cd34 stem cells and they will just go
into the bone marrow and graft and then
start producing all of the immune cells
that um they would normally produce any
of the blood cells any of the immune
cells so after a number of weeks um
these mice sort of have a fully
functional human immune system and then
we can utilize that as a surrogate for
what we may or may not see within a
patient of course that's not fully
translate translatable because it's the
mouse but it's as close as we can get um
before going to some of these higher
order model systems like um non-human
Pates which is probably the closest you
could get to a human but at least they
have the uh a competent human immune
system and we can show that it's able to
clear some of our CT cells and see them
as foreign which sort of replicates what
everyone's seeing in the clinic I see
and so uh how do you then actually mimic
the cancers or what type of solids uh
tumors in this case were you trying to
uh
mimic so in the paper we chose two
different models of lung cancer so we
were specifically focused on lung cancer
um we had screened a number of different
solid tumor model systems um anywhere
from
pancreatic um to melanoma to breast to
ovarian and really what we did up front
was phenotype all of these different
cancer cells and try to understand what
immunosuppressive Pathways might be
highly upregulated across these
so we were very focused on the adenosine
pathway coming from my lab at
Northeastern so we were sort of looking
at Tor types that had high expression of
this pathway lung cancer one of the lung
cancers we found was really high
expressing of this pathway so we started
with that um just because we were mainly
focused on The Knockout of the adenosine
receptor so we want to make sure there's
a lot of adenosine in the system and can
we prevent that immune suppression after
we chose that lung cancer model and
realized there might be other stuff in
the tumor micro environment we need to
be wary of we just stuck with that model
um more deeply characterized that and
found it also highly expressed other
suppressive Pathways that we were
interested in which sort of was the the
lead on to the paper and we were like
okay we have this tool it can Multiplex
Genet it we found multiple Pathways of
suppression let's see if we can layer
some on and really protect these two
cells interesting and so um now that
you've shown in some preclinical
evidence in the humanized mice what kind
of is like the next stage or where where
do you see this heading
next yeah I think that um this was just
a great POC to show you know there are
Pathways within the tumor micro
environment that can be
synergistic um if removed so you know
there might be certain Pathways that you
remove both and there's no additive
effect right they they they sort of feed
into the same type of pathway of how
they would suppress the t- cells we sort
of try to pick different ones that would
have different suppressive function and
it does seem like the more we remove the
more benefit we see for the te- cells so
I think that
this um can extend beyond that right so
can we do seven can we do eight can we
find other Pathways that are more
synergistic I think it's going to be
relatively challenging right um if you
can think of doing a 10px edit or a 20
FX edit how do you how do you rationally
design that I think it was a little
challenging already to come up with
combinations of things and to test them
in the lab and the mice so I really see
that this as a really great Avenue for
AI machine learning I know that's fuzzy
and everyone is into that now but if you
can imagine trying to come up with the
best combination of 20 edits how do you
pick those Pathways it sort of seems
almost Limitless but I think with the
Advent of machine learning it can really
understand what are these Pathways how
do they interplay with each other what
might be the most important and the
least important and how do those
actually combine to suppress the te-
cells so I think we're probably heading
in that direction of utilizing machine
learning more for a rational design but
I think up until that point just really
diving deeper into these tumor micro
environments trying to best understand
you know what does this look like what
immune cells are a there because once we
understand what immune cells are there
we might understand what Pathways
they're using to suppress um the immune
system because a lot of them are
polarized to procancer and then above
and beyond that what are the cancer
cells and those procancer immune cells
secreting you know there's a lot of
small things biochemical things like
adenosine that they're secreting there's
a lot of proteins and chemokines and
cyto that they're secreting which can
also suppress the immune system so
really understand ing what that tme
fingerprint looks like I think will be
an advantage to sort of more rationally
design these combinatorial edits right
now I think people are starting where we
started and saying there's a lot of
adenosine let's remove that and not
really thinking of all of those other
things because it's not usually that
straightforward to design something for
20 targets right imagine coming up with
20 small molecule Inhibitors or 20
antibody products that's really kind of
challenging to design and and then
understand the pkpd of that understand
the safety of that so I think up until
this point it's been really challenging
people have shied away from that um but
I think with the flexibility of crisper
and bass editing where designing these
guides is is high throughput now is is
more well understood and potentially
using some of these machine learning
algorithms to guide us into what is the
best combination I think is the next
step yeah I mean you for sure have hit
all the bzw criser
sales and AI as well um but in the paper
you uh to achieve some of these more
edits you also use like cast 12b is that
right like so why you using two
different types of crisper systems to
achieve the
multiplexing yeah so originally due to
those restrictive targeting sites of
Base editing where we really needed
somewhere close to the
protospacer um and somewhere that we
could edit in that start or one of those
splicers again you don't always find a
high editing um guide so for the Target
that we're targeting which is TGF beta
receptor 2 we didn't find high
efficiency editing um we could have used
something that was a little bit lower
editing but we decided let's try a
different editor so you could use a
different bass editor there are a lot of
different flavors of bass editors of
where they can be um delivered to what
types of things they edit Etc um but we
used a nucleus because crisper typically
is really easy to place anywhere in the
genome and it's really good at cutting
highly efficient at cutting so we
weren't concerned that we would get low
efficacy um with the generation of those
double St breaks so we switch to using a
nucleus called cwol B which actually has
an alternative Pam sequence to the base
editor so that means that they're going
to go to different regions in the genome
so there's no worry
that you know the the nucleus would then
be guided to where the base editor
should be guided to and vice versa so
they're going to only be editing with
the guides that are specific to them so
they have different protospacers and
different scaffold sequences so it's
really was amendable to um multiplexing
if we had used a traditional cast 9
which has the same scaffold and same um
pan Motif as the Bas editor it might get
guided to where the base was and
generate all of these double breaks that
we didn't want in the first place so we
chose cast 12b um because we knew it
would have high efficiency in editing
and it could be multiplexed with ape um
we found that it was really efficient at
knocking out the TGF beta receptor too
um so we just layered that in again to
show some novelty that we can pair these
things together because there's also
some implications you know where you
might want to add something into the
genome base editing is not typically
great at that because it doesn't gener
generate double Str breaks and you
really need to break apart the genome to
insert a gene where you want um so that
gives us that flexibility of do we want
to insert a car somewhere specific we
would use a nucleas do we want to insert
you know some of these cyto receptors we
would need a nucleus so it really gives
us that flexibility for Next Step so if
we do want to insert something
specifically into the genome um that
being said you know we sort of went back
and designed some new guides with the a
editor um to Target
other components of the tjf beta
receptor and we can actually get high
efficiency editing with the base editor
so we can do all of them with the Abe
now but um I think it was really amazing
to see that we could be flexible with
our editor choice and gives us you know
that additional um potential to insert
something if we so needed to yeah I
think that's one of the awesome things
about crispo and especially
uh well how mod modulable that's not
really but the idea that once you got
the the cast 9 protein it's just about
adding in the RN the guide rnas which
obviously are much smaller in size
compared to the protein which helps with
multiplexing um at least that's my
understanding right yeah yes and so how
would then then what are like the
challenges of going from this system to
actually getting it in fivo as you
mentioned earlier as been like another
sort of therapeutic approach as I think
delivery from my more naive perspective
is like the main challeng MH yeah I
think for for car T cells definitely
delivery is is a huge challenge so a lot
of the Delivery Systems right now are um
based on lmps and just getting them to
specifically traffic or engineer the te-
cells in the body is quite challenging
just based on the nature of their
chemistry they really preferentially go
to the liver um so there's a lot of you
know you'll probably see a lot of um
news about liver type diseases and those
are probably why they're being chosen
first because they're really easily
accessible for editing based on the lmps
um car T cell in Vivo engineering right
now I think is is modest so the
efficiency is quite low um and making
sure it's specific is is quite
challenging so you know you don't want
to go in and edit B cells or you don't
want to go in and edit macro Pages
potentially so it's going to a bunch of
other cell types that could have
negative effects um in theory if the car
is designed properly and it's only
targeting cancer it shouldn't be that
toxic but again you sort of lose that um
control over your system where we can do
all of our editing outside the body if
something went wrong or the batch didn't
look right or the editing wasn't good
you just wouldn't use that you see it
and that wouldn't be a therapy in the
body I think the the risk tolerance is a
lot lower because you do lose that
control so I think for now the delivery
to get them specifically and stably to
te- cells has been a challenge and
there's a ton of different Labs a ton of
different companies that are working on
strategies of making this more specific
and delivering them to te- cells so I
know LMP is is high in everyone's list
maybe sort of redirecting them to only
go to te- cells um there's a lot of
viruses that are being modified because
we know in the lab viruses very easy
infect te- cells so that's another mode
of delivery that people are trying to
use but has relatively low capacity for
what genes you can you know and or what
delivery cargo you can use to engineer
the te- cells and there's some fomes
which are are more um directed towards
te- cells that can actually deliver
these payloads in Vivo as well so I
think those are sort of the three major
buckets that people are using but right
now it's it's relatively um n fields for
CT Cell Therapy but there's also some
other areas outside of oncology where
you don't really need a high number of
tea cells or them to last for a long
time to enact their function so we're
seeing some of those Avenues take off
now and that might really help with some
of these um delivery developments
because the bar is much lower in some of
these other indications where you'll
need you know a small percentage of te-
cells to be transduced and then enact
their function for a small amount of
time whereas cancer you know you really
need to overwhelm the cancer and
overwhelm that amount of suppression
that it's bringing so you really need a
large number of te- cells that are
anti-cancer and they really need to stay
in the body for as long as possible to
fully eradicate that so I'm I'm hopeful
that um now that we're going outside of
oncology with some of these delivery
techs for te- cells that that will um
put a lot more resources behind
developing these delivery techs and it
might we might see a new surgents coming
back for um oncology with stronger more
specific delivery oh interesting and so
it seems definitely then like the most
short-term promising solution is these
allergenic uh approaches um and so I
guess even from that if you can have
these like super tea cells is there some
uh logic that there could be a sort of
universal anti-cancer ctis Cel or is the
always the C the the chimeric antigen
receptor itself that need to be
different for each
canel yeah I think people use the term
Universal um cartis Cel for that
allgenic purpose so you can think of you
know you just create one T Cell which is
shielded from the immune system and you
can use it for anyone everywhere or um
they have some of these Universal C t-
cells which you can much more easily
swap out that car right the ones that we
use right now are engineered in the lab
and the car that we put in is the car
that stays there there are some other
companies that sort of are a little bit
more modular and can be modular in the
patient as well where they sort of
Infuse the cancer targeting portion of
the car into the patient and it creates
the car in Vivo so if you need to switch
to your targeting Mo you can actually
just Infuse different ones and they'll
stick to the ctis cell so those are also
another type of
universal I think uh Universal antigen
is is probably a little bit more
challenging I think depending on the
cancer even the subtype of cancer they
all have different things that we would
like to Target um I think the cv19 space
um for some of these B cell leukemias in
lymphomas is as universal as we might
get um just because it's it's a marker
that identifies a B cell and these
cancers happen to be in B cells so that
is sort of a little bit more wider
spread for these Bell leukemias where
it's more of a universal antigen um but
then we wouldn't be able to use a cd19
for like a lung cancer let's say so I
think the targeting universality is
probably more limited but creating a
universal ctis cell whether it's fully
stealth and not going to be uh Alo
rejected or flexible and changing that
antigen um I think are definitely things
that are on the horizon um but not to
say that you know some of these solid
tumors might have similar antigens so
just because I use the model system in
the paper but just because we used lung
cancer doesn't mean we couldn't have
used breast cancer with that same car so
there is a little bit of flexibility
there um just finding cancers that
express the same antigens um they would
just be a smaller subset I see and so
how long do you think it will take for
some of these um like pre-clinical stage
approaches to actually get to clinical
trials yeah I think Gene editing in
general is very new um so I think think
there's been a little bit of a hangup
with regulatory bodies of Are We
comfortable with Gene editing do we
understand Gene editing or not um
because all these phase one trials right
are from a regulatory perspective mainly
focused on safety and they don't want to
put in these new technologies which sort
of have been rapid fire developed right
I think um the crisper Resurgence or
explosion was really only came out in
you know 2015 2016 um and already we
have these these Technologies in in
people and have cured people um so
typically a drug development cycle could
be 10 20 30 years and the crisper
Revolution sort of has shrunk that
completely so I think it's great that
we're starting to get things into
patience and seeing that these these
types of strategies are really effective
and actually have been really safe so I
think that is just going to sort of open
up this um regulatory landscape and what
can we do how can we be a little bit
more Innovative in how we view these
therapies we're learning a lot in the
lab and R&D of developing certain
analytical tools to make sure that these
are what we think they are and make sure
that they are as safe as we think they
are so I think that is is really coming
up quickly and I think once we have a
few of these in clinical trials I think
the pace will be much quicker it's
already been I think lightning speed but
I think coming from something coming
from scratch right now typically you
would say you know it won't be in people
for 20 years because that's just normal
drug development life cycle but I think
just the flexibility of these tools and
how much we're learning about these
tools and how powerful they are there's
so many companies and so many Labs
putting a lot of resources behind
studying these things that we're we're
learning so much so quickly that I think
this has really been shortened so I
would not be surprised if we saw
something brand new some of these new
technologies right like a prime editor
or some Gene writing or all these Gene
circuits which are relatively new I
wouldn't be surprised to see some of
those from idea to phase ones in
somewhere five six years at this point
they're sort of all building on each
other um but yeah I think I think the
pace is increasing which is great you
know I think that's the only way to
really find out if they're effective is
to get them into phase one and try to
help as many patients as possible so I
think the IND you know as researcher I'm
really excited to see some of that
reality and see how these things are
working and then you know for the
patients like they're waiting for these
therapies and having to wait 20 years
for someone to develop something some of
these more intricate therapies is it is
a hindrance right it's a struggle so I
think now that we can do things more
quickly iteratively again with high
throughput stuff with machine learning
potentially I think this is going to go
much much faster in the in the future
awesome yeah I know I I agree I think
there's definitely a lot of potential
but we have to obviously be careful and
make sure um it's going to be effective
and safe at the same time so I know
right now from having swing to you
Offline that you're now uh as I a
similar position to myself a couple of
months ago in the thesis writing stage
um so uh while I know you're going to be
busy doing all that uh what other things
are you excited to see on the like the
Horizon yeah um I think that a lot of
these combinations I'm biased because
the paper was Genting combinations um I
think anything combination though is
going to be really important moving
forward we're seeing now a lot in the in
the context of cancer you know can we
combine multiple biologics I think
that's shown a ton of Promise by
combining a pd1 and ctla4 blockade so
that's showing more efficacy over um
just pd1 itself just recently we saw
some some data come out that was pd1 lag
3 shows much more efficacy over pd1
itself um combination with either those
immunotherapies with analytic virus or
cares with analytic virus I think we're
really starting to understand
that being as restrictive as we were
before you know biology is really
complex human diseases are really
complex but choosing something that we
knew you know this is the one target
this is the one molecule for that one
target we're really good at that but
it's just not it's just not complex
enough to really address the challenges
that we're seeing in real human health
and now we're just I think on the edge
of realizing you know these single
modalities are just not really going to
cut it and how can we best combine them
whether it's combining a bunch of
genetics maybe but maybe we need to
combine those combination of genetics
with an analytic virus so that's
something that I think is on the
Forefront everyone's really trying to
understand how do we best combine
Technologies which makes it even more
challenging right typically you're an
expert in one specific thing and now you
need these other things you don't really
understand them fully enough to combine
them um so I think there's going to be a
lot more cross talk between Labs between
companies between Partnerships um to
really you know think we need to come up
with a best therapeutic and how do we do
that we need to sort of work together so
I'm hoping that that is is the trend in
the industry and in Academia is really
combining all of these things to combat
how complicated any of these human
diseases are yeah that well said I mean
I agree science is challenging but also
very rewarding and especially when you
can have that element of creativity as
well to create something successful so
well yeah firstly thank you for speaking
with me today and breaking down that
preprint hopefully it does get accepted
and published sometime soon um and yeah
best of luck with the write up for your
thesis awesome yeah thank you so much
and thanks for inviting me had a great
time